beating slurs and the pop quiz from Hell
1923 is off to a brutal start but did
that tiona scene go just a little bit
too far
who would have thought we'd ever be so
afraid of soap in the premiere of the
Yellowstone spin-off 1923 the seemingly
innocuous cleaning product contributes
to one of the episode's most shocking
disturbing and violent scenes the
moments in question sees tiona rainwater
a boarding school student get asked to
name the nine ingredients of soap by her
strict religious teacher Sister Mary oil
lie in water
what kind of oil
any kind
when tiona can't recall the ingredients
the nun proceeds to beat her with a
ruler which prompts the student to
Spring from her chair and start throwing
fists of course it's easy to sympathize
with tiona here as she's clearly being
persecuted the school isn't exactly
enlightened when it comes to human
rights after all and Taylor Sheridan's
work never shies away from showcasing
the uglier side of History furthermore
the nun refers to tiona as an animal in
similar slurs highlighting the
mistreatment and Prejudice that the girl
faces at the religious institution
however while many 1923 viewers sided
with the boarding school students they
were still shocked by the violent nature
of the scene following the episode some
fans took to social media to share their
thoughts on the matter while the scene
in question will go down in history as a
polarizing one it certainly got people
talking unsurprisingly many people hated
the boarding school scene but some
people felt it was necessary in order to
get the show's point across regardless
of which side of the debate the social
media user sided with many of them
agreed that the scene was unexpected one
user wrote the boarding school scene in
1923 probably should have had a trigger
warning this sentiment was shared by
another user whose said 1923 giving me
something I was truly not expecting in
the scene when the nun gets absolutely
rocked elsewhere some viewers were
disgusted by what they saw and were
quick to make their feelings known one
person said 1923 is a good reason I
don't watch shows sick awful on the flip
side some fans claim that the scene was
necessary in order to highlight the
persecution faced by Native American
students especially during the time in
which the show's story is set one
Twitter user said love that 1923 has
incorporated the native perspective on
the colonizing Catholic schools it's
hard to watch but so impactful for
movies such as Wind River to the show
set in the Yellowstone Universe Taylor
Sheridan has always tried to shed a
light on indigenous characters his work
also highlights the displacement and
mistreatment that Native Americans have
faced throughout history which obviously
isn't pretty unfortunately for viewers
with queasy stomachs this means having
to sit through some truly disturbing
sequences such as the boarding school
scenes in 1923. indeed the messed up
history of Native American boarding
schools has been well documented in the
late 19th and early 20th centuries the
United State's government funded a
program called the federal Indian
boarding school initiative which was
designed to assimilate native children
into American culture that meant taking
children from their parents and placing
them in schools far away from their
homes where they were often beaten and
abused by their teachers 1923 is
authentic in that regard Sheridan's work
has always been political and 1923 is
clearly no different the show is
certainly disturbing at times but at the
end of the day that's more or less the
whole point
[Music]
thank you